hey everyone welcome back and let's
write some more new code today so today
let's solve the problem valid palindrome
i'm actually going to be solving this
two different ways and i think both ways
are definitely going to be helpful to
know in an interview setting before we
start i just want to quickly mention
that this problem is actually a part of
the blind 75 list of questions and
luckily we have actually solved the vast
majority of the blind 75 questions i
even have a playlist of all of these
questions in the description if you want
to take a look and of course we will be
finishing one more today getting one
step closer to 100 completion of blind
75 so we are given a string s all we
want to do is determine if it's a
palindrome uh if it is we can return
true if it's not we return false uh only
one catch is that we are only
considering alphanumeric characters in
the list and we are ignoring cases by
ignoring cases they mean upper and lower
case so in the input string you can see
the leftmost character is capital a the
rightmost character is lowercase a both
of these characters are considered the
same so if we had a string an input
string like big a lower a this string
itself is a palindrome so we do return
true even though one is uppercase and
one is lowercase we are ignoring the
cases of the characters uh and also when
they say we're only considering
alphanumeric characters basically it
means we can ignore everything that's
not an alphanumeric character what is
alphanumeric basically everything from
uppercase a to uppercase z everything
from lowercase a to lowercase c and
everything from zero all the way to nine
right every character and every digit so
basically in this input string it might
not look like a palindrome initially but
the answer is yes true it is a
palindrome because and actually before
we even get into that what is a
palindrome if you don't remember well
basically the easiest way to check if a
string is a palindrome is basically if
it reads uh the same way as it does when
it is reversed meaning if the string is
the exact same even after it's been
reversed so for example a b a if we
reverse this string it's still a b a so
it is a palindrome right so and let's
take this string if we reverse it is it
still the exact same basically if we
read it in reverse order and the answer
is yes let's just compare a few
characters initially let's start at the
beginning right a uh and remember we're
ignoring case so when i say ignoring
case i'm just going to basically convert
it to lowercase so everything is just
going to be lower okay so we have an a
okay next character is a space character
but remember we're only considering
alphanumeric so we don't even consider
the space we want to skip that space so
just delete it right
next character m
and then next character a next character
n so we just took this from the
beginning of the string a man right so
let's start at the end of the string uh
we have a lowercase a right and then we
have a lowercase m then we have a
lowercase a then we have lowercase n so
even starting at the end of the string
it looks like it's the same as the
beginning when we read it in reverse and
it turns out that if we you know take
this string and remove
all the spaces all the special
characters and then convert everything
else to lowercase and then we reverse it
it will be the exact same string and
that's the approach i'm going to be
taking i'm just going to be removing i'm
going to be filtering all the useless
characters from this keeping the
characters that we want and then
converting them to lowercase then
reversing the string and then checking
if it's still equal so now let's get
into the coding solution at least the
first coding solution okay so now let's
code it up and remember we're going to
be building the new string which is just
going to be removing all the
non-alphanumeric characters from the
input string so this solution is kind of
the cheating solution where i'm going to
be using a lot of built-in functions and
extra memory as well so we're going to
just iterate through every single
character in the string s if that
character is alphanumerical and the good
thing is python and actually i think
most uh libraries most languages like
java have a built-in function to check
if a character or a string is
alphanumerical python at least does so
we're checking if this character is
alphanumerical if it is we want to
include it in the new string so we're
going to go ahead and take that
character and add it to the new string
but one thing you don't want to forget
is we want to make sure that every
character is lowercase so before we add
it to the new string we want to make
sure that it is lowercase so we'll
convert it to lowercase and then we're
done with that we have the new string we
removed all the other characters from it
now we just want to check if it is the
exact same when it has been reversed
so we're just going to take this new
string compare it to the reversed string
which in python you can do like this
by you know this is the syntax for
reversing a string so if they are equal
then we can return true if they're not
equal this will return false which is
what we want to do to determine if it's
a palindrome so now let's run the code
and make sure that it works as you can
see on the left yes it does work but
there are some deficiencies with the
solution that maybe your interviewer
won't want you to use maybe they won't
want you to use this alphanumerical
function and they want you to implement
it yourself and maybe they don't want
you to use extra memory clearly we use
extra memory by building the new string
and we actually used extra memory over
here when we reversed the string we
created a new string that was the
reversal of the original so let's see
how we can actually improve this
solution okay so now let's see how we
can actually solve this problem with
constant extra memory without using
extra memory without creating a new
version of this string and the main way
is going to be by using pointers so
we're going to have two pointers a left
pointer and a right pointer because
remember there are multiple ways to
check if a string is a palindrome we
don't have to reverse it we can just
compare the left character and the
rightmost character if they're equal
then we shift the pointers in the left
pointer comes here and the right pointer
goes here and then we can continue to
check to make sure that the characters
are equal if they're not equal then we
return but how do we know when to stop
well we're going to keep incrementing
the left pointer and we're going to keep
decrementing the right pointer until
eventually they meet in the middle or
the left pointer you know passes the
right pointer right the left pointer
becomes here and the right pointer is
over here that's how we know when we can
stop or maybe they will meet
exactly at the same character if the
length of the string happens to be odd
okay so that's actually pretty simple
not too bad so what are we gonna do okay
left is here right is here this is
capital a but of course we're gonna
convert it to lowercase this is
lowercase a so they're equal right okay
so then right pointer is gonna be
decremented by one so the right pointer
is going to be over here at the m
character left corner is going to be
incremented by one and it's going to be
here well we're at the space character
but remember we want to ignore spaces we
want to ignore everything except for
alphanumerical characters and can we try
to do this without using a built-in
function well let me show you how we can
kind of do that basically i did some
quick googling and we're actually going
to use ascii values to determine if a
character is alphanumerical basically
what you need to know is that each
symbol
you know ascii symbols is 128 of them
and lowercase and uppercase english
characters happen to have an ascii value
associated with them you can see the
integer 0 has an ascii value associated
48 uh integer 1 has 49 integer 2 has 50
so they are contiguous all the way down
to integer 9 which is at 57. so that's
important and we also have uppercase a
starting at 65 going all the way down
to 90. they are contiguous as well and
then eventually we can get to lowercase
starting at 97 going all the way down to
122. these are contiguous as well using
this information in pretty much every
language you can write your own
alphanumerical character detecting
function and i'll show you how to do
that in a few minutes but for now just
assume that we do have our own
alphanumerical function and our left
pointer is over here what do we want to
do we don't really want to compare this
character with the character m on the
right side do we because we want to skip
this character so how do we skip it well
we can create a while loop
so while our left pointer is not
alphanumerical then we're gonna
increment left right we're gonna do left
plus plus we're gonna keep incrementing
left while it is not a alphanumerical
character because we want to ignore uh
characters that are not alphanumeric so
we're gonna increment left one more time
now luckily it is a alphanumerical
character it's the character m so we
compare left and right they're exactly
the same so we continue with our
algorithm we uh decrement r over here
increment left over here right now
they're both at the same character and
we're going to continue the algorithm so
that's the main idea i won't run through
this entire string because it's pretty
long but eventually the strings will
meet in the middle for example over here
somewhere maybe at that point we'll see
okay they're at the same character and
then we'll say we can stop our algorithm
we've determined it is a palindrome and
then we can return true so now let me
show you how to code it up the benefit
of this solution it is still a linear
time algorithm it's still big o of n
because we have to iterate through the
entire string but the memory complexity
is big o of one because we're not using
any extra memory in this case okay so
now let's get into the code first thing
i'm going to do is write our alpha
numerical function so
it's going to take in a single parameter
just going to take in a character and
then we're going to determine if that
character is alphanumeric or not how can
we determine that well i was using the
ascii values a moment ago right i was
talking about them so in python you can
get the ascii value of a character uh
using the ord function we just want to
know that the ascii value of this
character if it is an uppercase
character how can we check that well as
i showed you a moment ago ascii values
are contiguous for uppercase characters
right so from uppercase a to uppercase z
uh they're contiguous so if the ascii
value of the c character of whatever
this character happens to be is between
the ascii value of uppercase a and
uppercase z that means it's an uppercase
character so that's good good so far
right that's progress for now we can
check that this is an uppercase
character but we want to check if it's
alphanumeric so we have to extend this
idea so how about we say okay that or
second condition i'm actually just going
to copy and paste this because it's
going to be similar we want to check if
it's a lowercase character right because
that's the next thing is it uppercase or
is it lowercase we can do that by taking
the ascii values of the lowercase a and
lowercase z and last it could be a digit
from zero to one or zero to nine
actually so let's do that same thing
right starting at zero is in between
zero or uh the integer nine if any of
these is true this will be true so
basically we've determined if it's an
alphanumeric or not that will that's
what this condition will be so we can go
ahead and return this so if it is
alphanumeric of course this will return
true if it's not alphanumeric this will
return false okay so we got our helper
function out of the way now let's
actually write the algorithm as i showed
in the drawing we're going to have two
pointers left and right left is gonna
initially be at zero right is initially
going to be all the way at the right
side so the length of the string minus
one and remember we want to continue the
algorithm we want to check if it's a
paundrome while the left pointer is less
than the right point the pointers have
not met each other yet or crossed each
other and so now we get to the point
where we actually want to compare the
characters so we want to take the
character at position left and the
character at position right and if
they're not equal we want to return
immediately right because if we find a
single pair that's not equal then we
know it's not a palindrome so we can
return false immediately
but did we forget about anything well
the first thing we forgot about is we
want to make sure to only compare the
lowercase versions of each character so
let's convert this to lower and convert
this to lower
so that's good we're so if one of these
is upper case one of them is lowercase
we're still good but did we forget about
anything else well we never called our
alphanumeric function right what if one
of these is not an alphanumeric
character well we can't have that right
we shouldn't allow that to happen so
before we even execute this if statement
let's make sure both characters at left
and right are alphanumeric so while it's
not alphanumeric so for example while
the character at position left is not
alphanumeric what do we want to do well
we want to increment that left pointer
right so we can uh plus 1 to this but
one thing we want to make sure is that
the pointer never goes out of bounds so
let's just add a checks to make sure
left is less than right for example this
will make sure that of course it never
passes the other pointer and it'll also
make sure that the pointer doesn't go
out of bounds and we want to make sure
to do the exact same thing
for the other position as well for the
right pointer so
make sure that right is greater than
left and
the character at the position right is
if it's not alphanumeric then what do we
want to do we want to decrement the
right pointer by one instead of
incrementing but but both of these while
loops will make sure that both
characters are alphanumeric before we do
the comparison which is what we wanted
to achieve so
then this will return false if it's not
a palindrome if the entire loop finishes
that must mean that the string is a
palindrome so then we can just go ahead
and return
true oh and actually one more thing
before i forget
after we do do the comparison we want to
update our left and right pointers right
we want to compare the next position so
to the left pointer we're going to
increment it by one to the right pointer
we're going to decrement it by one so
just moving to the next position to do
the next comparison on the next
iteration of the while loop so now this
is the entire code so let's just run it
to make sure that it works okay i was
dumb in python if you want to call
another function inside of an object you
have to use the self keyword so let's
try that one more time and as you can
see on the left yes it does work but
it's actually slightly less efficient
than the other solution even though the
big o time complexity is the exact same
and the memory complexity of the
solution is actually better than the
other one this is no extra memory needed
as you can see so i really hope that
this was helpful if it was please like
and subscribe it really supports the
channel a lot consider checking out my
patreon where you can further support
the channel and hopefully i'll see you
pretty soon thanks for watching